today we have an appointment at Dr
Morales office to get the results for
the anti-malarian human test and that's
the test that will determine how many
excels I have left I'm amen for the
doctor to give me good news stating that
I'm still 100 fertile
you ready
let's go here's some good news
I do think still kind of put in a cart
before the horse maybe a little bit
um because there's hasn't been any
issues uh thank God and no just some of
the things she's told to me about her
and her family like pretty fertile you
know needless to say so hopefully uh
that will continue to be this that same
way to you my lady
Hi how are you hello you guys checking
in for an appointment today yes with Dr
mirabile so if you want to have a seat
over here they'll be out shortly to get
you all right thank you thank you
anytime a doctor calls you into the
office rather than giving you the
results virtually sometimes you you do
tend to think something could shift and
go wrong
I am a lot nervous but I'm trying to
just continue myself
good
I'm glad nauseous nauseous
nervous nervous
Dr Mora was very dizzy you know
[Music]
Maybe
thank you thank you
have a seat
well we've got some things to talk about
we did the blood work and I talked to
you the other day about the amh or the
anti-mullerian hormone it's testing the
amount of eggs that you have left to be
fertilized but the test that we did on
you did come back
saying that your ovarian reserve is low
this is not a predictor that you can get
pregnant it just means that hey time is
of the essence as far as getting things
going if we want to have a natural
childbirth spontaneously
foreign